BRADY HARAN: So today I'm going
to do something I've
never done before, I'm
going to phone a
Numberphile file viewer.
And the reason for that is this
viewer has a very special
phone number.
So while I get ready
to do this, let's
get on with the video.
DR. JAMES GRIME: This
came from Brady.
So you heard of this
type of number.
So it was a type number called
pandigital numbers.
And when you mentioned it, I
said well, I've heard of
pandigital numbers and I even
have a favorite one.
So that says start off my
favorite pandigital number.
I'll show you what they
are, as well.
381,654,729.
This is my favorite
pandigital number.
Well, first of all, what's
a pandigital number?
You may notice from that number
it uses every digit.
And it uses every digit once
there from one to nine.
So that's called a pandigital
number.
This one's my favorite.
It has an extra property because
the first end digits
of it is divisible by n.
I'll show you what I mean.
The first digit is
divisible by 1.
The first two digits
are divisible by 2.
The first three digits,
so 381, is a number
divisible by 3.
First four is a number
divisible by 4.
That's divided by 5.
That can be divided
by 6, 7, 8, and 9.
And that's the only pandigital
number where that works.
So this is a unique pandigital
number with
that special property.
-It hasn't got a zero.
DR. JAMES GRIME: It
hasn't got a zero.
So there are different
definitions
for pandigital numbers.
Some are more strict
than others.
So some definitions allow you
to repeat the numbers.
So you can repeat the
digits as long as
you have all of them.
Some of you don't allow you
to repeat the digits.
Some definitions allow
you to have zero.
So that one would be a zeroless
pandigital number.
If you like, though, shall
I stick zero in it?
What I could do is put
a zero on the end.
And, then, there's a
number that can be
divided by 10, as well.
And that's also unique.
So that would be a unique
pandigital number including
zero, that could be
divided by 10.
Of course, we can't
divide by zero.
-Nice improvisation there.
DR. JAMES GRIME: You like that?
-Yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
BRADY HARAN: So you've probably
figured out by now
the person I'm going to call has
a pandigital phone number.
I found out about it by putting
a message out on
Facebook and Twitter.
So if you don't follow
Numberphile on Facebook and
Twitter that's something
you need to be doing.
But before I make this phone
call, here's James with a bit
more information about
pandigital numbers.
DR. JAMES GRIME: The smallest
pandigital number-- pandigital
by the way, it sounds like a
radio station on Neverland.
Did you like that?
There you go.
-No, I didn't particularly
like that.
I think pandigital sounds
like a really
modern way of cooking.
DR. JAMES GRIME: Pandigital.
Yeah, yeah, I agree.
I like that too.
The smallest pandigital number
is one billion--
this has a zero in it.
So one billion and the
rest, 23,456,789.
So you can kind of see that
that one's the smallest
pandigital because you can't
put the zero at the start.
You can see why that's the
smallest pandigital number.
Here's another type of
pandigital number.
This one's going
to be a square.
So that's going to
be 9,814,072,356.
That's not necessarily the
largest pandigital number.
But it's the largest square
pandigital number.
So that's square because it has
a square root that is a
whole number as well.
Do you want me to check it?
356.
And I want to check that's
a square number.
Yeah, look at that.
So 99,066 That's
a cool number.
Is it 99,066?
Or is it 99,066.
I'm not sure.
I'm not sure what is.
-I see what you're
doing there.
I like the upside.
What are they called?
Numbers that look the
same upside down.
DR. JAMES GRIME: Oh, well there
must be a name for that.
-We'll do a different
video on them.
DR. JAMES GRIME: I don't
know if that was
an interesting fact.
-Yeah.
DR. JAMES GRIME: Oh, but you'll
like a prime, won't
you?
-Oh, a prime pandigital.
DR. JAMES GRIME: You want a
prime pandigital number.
I thought you'd like that.
So it's 10,123,457,689.
That's one of the looser
definitions of pandigital--
cause you can see I've used
the one twice there--
definition.
But that's a prime
number as well.
So how many pandigital
numbers are there?
If we get really strict first of
all, so we use every digit
once and once only, then, it's
just rearranging the first,
well, these numbers here
from one to nine.
I'll not include zero to start
with cause that's going to
make things a bit
more difficult.
The number of ways you can
rearrange the numbers from one
to nine to make a pandigital
number is
going to be nine factorial.
Nine factorial, which
is 362,880.
And I reckon if we're allowed
to have zero, as well, then,
it could go anywhere except
the first place.
So with zero, it's going
to be 9 times
9 factorial, 3,265,920.
-This is obviously purely
a recreational thing.
DR. JAMES GRIME: That's
And I know some people don't
like it when we're doing
things that are base
10 centric.
And this is a base 10 centric
little fun thing to do.
If we try base 2, which
only allows us to
use ones and zeroes.
Well, then, all numbers are
going to be pandigital in that
case, except for numbers
that are one less
than a power of two.
Cause in base 2 those
are 1111111.
So those are the only ones that
wouldn't be pandigital.
BRADY HARAN: So here we go.
I'm going to be calling this
number for our viewer, Lara,
who is in the Netherlands with
a pandigital number.
And if you don't include the
area code it's a brilliant
pandigital number, very pure.
Every digit just once.
Shall we give it a go?
I have no idea what's going
to happen here.
[PHONE RINGS]
LARA: Hello, it's Lara.
BRADY HARAN: Hello,
is that Lara?
LARA: Hi, yes, it is.
BRADY HARAN: Lara, it's
Brady Haran, here.
LARA: Hi, I'm doing good.
BRADY HARAN: How
are you doing?
LARA: I'm just going into the
other room because I can't
hear you very well.
Hang on.
BRADY HARAN: OK.
LARA: All right.
I should be able to
hear you now.
BRADY HARAN: So I have to say
this is the first time I've
ever phoned a pandigital
phone number.
LARA: Really?
BRADY HARAN: Oh, I think so.
I don't know.
It's the first time I've
done it knowingly.
LARA: I'm always telling people
when I give them my
phone number, I go, look
it has all the numbers.
How cool is that?
And nobody ever thinks
it's cool, but I do.
BRADY HARAN: Oh, well, I
think it's very cool.
And I think a lot of the people
who watch our video
will think it's very cool.
LARA: I hope so.
[LAUGHTER]
BRADY HARAN: What do you-- tell
us about you, though.
What do you do and stuff?
LARA: I'm a student.
I study psychology.
BRADY HARAN: Psychology
student.
LARA: Yeah.
BRADY HARAN: What are you doing
watching Numberphile videos?
LARA: I really like maths
but I'm very bad at it.
So Numberphile is sort
of a comfortable in
between spot for me.
BRADY HARAN: Well, we're
obviously not going to tell
anyone your phone number, but
thank you for sharing the
glory of your pandigital
phone number with us.
LARA: Yeah, it is glorious.
Isn't it?
BRADY HARAN: Yeah, thanks so
much for being part of, I
guess, bit of a silly video.
But, hopefully, when you watch
it you'll learn lots of other
stuff about pandigital
numbers, too
LARA: Yeah, I'm really looking
forward to it.
BRADY HARAN: Excellent.
Well, you're the star
of the show, now.
So I hope you're looking
forward to it.
[LAUGHTER]
BRADY HARAN: Alright.
All the best.
Have a good evening.
LARA: Yeah, you too.
Bye bye.
BRADY HARAN: Bye.
[PHONE DISCONNECTS]
BRADY HARAN: There you go.
Pandigital phone number.
How cool was that?
A special thanks to
squarespace.com for supporting
this video.
Squarespace is this all-in-one
platform for designing
websites and blogs and
online stores.
Why don't you check them out?
These are some websites that
have been designed using it.
They're pretty slick looking.
Much more impressive than
the Numberphile website.
So go and have a look.
It's free to join up.
And if you decide to use it
and purchase anything from
them, you can actually get 10%
off by using numberphile5 as
the voucher code.
I actually contacted them and
asked if we could change it to
numberphile and then a
pandigital number, but I think
someone decided that'd probably
be a bit complicated.
So we're going with
numberphile5.
Anyway, enough about that.
squarespace.com.
Free to join up.
If you buy anything, use
the code, numberphile5.
And thanks to them for
supporting us and helping us
make videos.